and finally new rule let me make the new
rules not the academy awards
if you missed it last week because the
state was on fire
the oscars thought it would be a good
time to announce a new set of
requirements for best picture nominees
that are based on fulfilling diversity
quotas
and look i'm all for inclusion i don't
know anyone in hollywood who isn't
okay mel gibson
but in general hollywood is a liberal
industry in a
liberal town in a state that's bluer
than the pope's
balls
have you watched the oscars this century
because
this really seems like a case of washing
a glass that's already been through the
dishwasher
the academy is not exactly unknown for
rewarding liberal virtue they should
call best picture most worthy
look at the contenders and winners in
recent years
been nominated not by their popularity
with audiences
but by diversity and virtue signaling
green book
parasite shape of water boys don't cry
a beautiful mind moonlight frida
fences precious dallas buyers club 12
years a slave
roma the hours brokebach mountain call
me by your name and many more some very
fine movies but getting super liberals
to be more liberal
is not exactly the heavy lifting in the
fight against racism
by the way there was a straight white
guy who was a big winner one year but it
was only because he had a crippling
speech impediment
[Applause]
anyway what the new rules say is to be
eligible for
to compete for best picture a film must
meet the standards of two
of four new inclusion groups group a a
story line that centers on or a star
that represents
an underrepresented identity group or
thirty percent of minor roles
from two underrepresented identity
groups which include
asian hispanic latinx black african
american indigenous native american
alaskan native
middle eastern north african native
hawaiian or other pacific islander
women lgbtq plus people people with
cognitive or physical disabilities or
who are deaf or hard of hearing
wouldn't it just be easier to say not
chris pine
and that's only group a then there's
stuff
worthy goals i'm sure about diversity in
the production company the studio and
the crew
all i know is if in the interest of
diversity they make a straight guy cut
my hair i'm [ __ ]
look diversity is important
but it needs to be said it's not the
only thing
that's important thank you one guy
it's also important that we don't wind
up with artists
guided less by a creative vision and
more by a to-do list
cameron diaz is cuban on her
grandfather's side
is that latina enough clint eastwood
is 200 years old does that count as a
handy
does that count as a handicap darth
vader is voiced by a black man but when
they took off his helmet the character
was white
how many points is that i want to know
so i can be good
because we are talking about a world
where if you want to make the next
schindler's list the first thing you'll
need to do is give
a racial breakdown of all your employees
does anyone see the irony in that
apparently not but um christie alley did
she tweeted
can you imagine telling picasso what had
to be in his [ __ ] paintings you
people have lost your minds
oscar orwell wow
you know hollywood is in trouble when
the voice of sanity is a scientologist
but she's right art and coercion is a
bad combination
some of the best movies ever made were
by refugees from communist
and fascist countries who got out
because they didn't like being told what
art was acceptable
they didn't want to make a movie called
natasha gets a tractor
we're supposed to be the free country
where artists can do what they want
without having to show your paperwork to
prove
you know where everyone comes from who
they [ __ ] and if they can hear
and given that the industry is reeling
as it is
and given that so much creativity and
originality has already been sucked out
of
movies by sequels blockbusters and comic
book franchises
and given that there's an election in
six weeks maybe this wasn't the time
for this move also
i gotta say
have they worked in this industry a long
time at the end of the day people don't
want to be hired because they filled the
quota
they want to be
they want to be hired because they're
good and most of them are